so the council's implemented a new three
strikes policy to ensure customers using
the curbside collection service are
using it correctly so customers get
three chances to recycle right on their
third strike the service is withdrawn
for a period of three months the three
strikes policy was implemented because
lace knit Southland did some research
into how customers are using the yellow
recycling bins and they found that a
third of customers weren't sorting their
recycling and rubbish correctly but the
policy is implemented both before and
during collection so contractors and
staff can check the band for compliance
if significant contamination is found in
the recycling bin that the policy is
enforced in a strike is applied so
currently we have approximately 250
properties on their first strike around
15 on their second strike and one
property has had the service fully
removed for a period of three months so
after the service has been removed in
the three month period is up customers
can contact Council again to reinstate
the service all right so here I found
this in a recycling bin so this is non
recyclable it looks like a cover off a
duvet or a sheet or something like that
so in this instance I would leave the
customer a green tag on their bin this
just lets them know that that minor
non-recyclables in there and it does not
issue them a strike as for minor
contamination so this is a really good
example of good recycling so we've got
the milk bottles are all cleaned out and
everything is loose in the bed are not
bagged up so we've got all of the loose
papers and cardboard and plastic things
like that in there all clean
I just been checking your yellow
recycling bin and you look like you're
doing a fantastic job
it's all clean yeah no it looks really
good yeah so the kind of things that
people are receiving stripes for is
putting clothing garden waste food
scraps in window glass in their
recycling bins more on the shocking side
is sanitary items and dead animals which
isn't pleasant for us to find when we're
inspecting all the people that certain
disability enterprises who have to hand
sort the recycling either okay
Awesome's springtime's coming so we'll
have lambs or little lambs it's quite
upsetting for the guys to see a puppy
come down the line they don't understand
how someone could be so terrible and
just chuck it in the bin and see the
baring it like most so if you're unsure
of what you can put in your yellow
recycling but there's a handy to stick
here under the lip which tells you what
can go in and what can't go in or if you
have an item and you're really not sure
if it can be recyclable or not just pop
it in your ribbon or if you're still
really unsure and you would like some
more information feel free to contact
council